what kind of songs do I sing
they're usually based pretty much on the
tonality of the situation and getting
and finding a tone that I can ride out
of the situation so and their
synesthesia I mean a tone like
[Music]
[Music]
you know you're feeling it's doing
something to you and you can steer your
way through weird stuff with this then
usually you become distracted and by the
act of making the sound itself because
the sound first of all you either have
or have the illusion that you have
tremendous control over the production
of tone your ear it gives you a
tremendous ability to differentiate
these tones and they're appearing in
front of you as colors if you're loaded
enough so you this is the modality in
which you can experiment with the
visible language you try to
syntactically construct out of tonality
and glossolalia some kind of convincing
modality most of you have probably heard
I'll wash this song 1a 1a 1b
CG they see Jason Jason JT they're
driving it's what they are they're
repetitious and they're driving and you
discover in yourself you know the
capacity for glossolalia which you can
ride you can lift the meaning governor
off of the language machinery and just
let it spin and it's indefensible as art
but ecstatic 2d you know I mean I tend
to do glossolalia switch are more
conversational and I like them because
they play with meaning so that's kind of
stuff sort of sounds like a deja my walk
secret eating is no
then Wow maybe is to the Hmong Wow
forgive me chica Katie can easy
yeah I do this alone in the dark and
what it is is its it places an edge for
the light to follow and you discover
[Music]
meaning in the absence of context and
you discover like the source of meaning
before it is contextually located
don't ask me what this kind of belief in
the words mean this is what I learned to
talk hanging out with these semiotics
people but it's something like that you
know and I think people did this for
hundreds of thousands of years for each
other as a form of performance art long
before somebody got the nuts and bolts
notion that you could connect and an
action in the world or as linguistic
intent to a sound that we're just set up
for this
these small mouth noises and it's
tremendously under the influence of of
psychedelics you know you can make
language get up and walk around I mean
you can literally peel it off the
ceiling and set it dancing in your
presence if any of you have read Robert
Graves books the white goddess he talks
in there about what he calls an
Earthship rock a visibly beheld language
of primal poetry and he thinks our
anxiety has to do with the fact that we
have lost the truth speech and that if
you speak the true language the
Earthship rock
it's a beheld language it doesn't
require the conventional ization of
dictionaries you know what you mean and
that the the loss of this genetic
language is what made us so maladaptive
our knees with ourselves
[Music]
you
[Music]